Okay, I'm about to go get my hair done,
but I wanted to show you my outfit
because I wanted to really dopamine dress today.
I'm wearing all of these things that just make me so incredibly happy.
Starting off with this Lily Am swing coat,
this vintage coat. So pretty.
It's like a dress on top of a dress.
And then bright colors. We're feeling,
like, the green and turquoise.
I added some of these vintage brooches.
And then I have the same colors kind of
in my earrings and my accessories
and these little booties.
Oh, and the.
And the purse. I'll take the strap off.
When you dress in a way that makes you happy,
it really changes your mood or it enhances your mood.
I just. I love color,
and I think this is so cute.